today on our show we got on we dog Joss
Whedon gets into the bit yeah that's
right that sounds filthy ornamented but
Joss Whedon is gonna make a bad girl
film and we're gonna [ __ ] dissect it
even though it's not been made today on
fat man I'm back
[Music]
welcome back to that naina Batman I'm
Kevin Smith hi I'm mark barnard okay man
this is [ __ ] news you see this [ __ ]
coming news me so let me tell you kids a
story about the superpowers ladies
gentlemen and that doesn't used to be in
America and Russia but of course now it
only means DC and Marvel when we were
kids reading comic books they would mean
show meet look I got a sweet signal when
we were given when we were kids reading
comic books kids we had the Battle of
which universe you like better do you
like DC you DC person you were Marvel
person blah blah blah and you know I
Stanley the guy we all know and love
look that [ __ ] up into a frenzy man as
the ambassador of comics he knew it was
good for sales awesome all in good fun
you talked to Stanley today he's never
liked [ __ ] hated DC but passion that
Hitler hated all like it was like fun
and games like he's he always stood for
distinguished competition yes they would
never even say like DC or something like
so dumb Cox that's what we do and
marvelous stock so so basically back in
the day you had a slight ride over here
between the two companies and then you
know earn enough [ __ ] people in the
comic book community at one point to
sustain a rivalry shock they never
became one company and there were rumors
that once or twice they don't it almost
happens can you imagine
until like Warner Brothers buys one and
you know Disney buys the other it's like
yeah okay maybe we're not gonna do that
now it was buried though where it might
have happened and I don't mean the
amalgam universe I mean like one company
could have owned all of those characters
every superhero you know well from the
big tube but in any event it's a long
time ago now you know what world we live
in
Marvel dominates the [ __ ] movie biz
and DC is playing catch-up Warner
Brothers bc / Warner Bros with building
an entire universe with one gigantic
movie BVS that dominates the TV biz oh
my god but DC if you want to watch a
fantastic story about comic book
characters using comic book characters
told lovingly but people craftspeople
that that know what the [ __ ] they're
doing because they grew up reading every
single one of these
characters every single issue of their
books yes the CW of course and now I'm
not just saying that cuz I've done a few
of those are the ones those are the
weakest links kids what you want to look
at is all the work that they've done on
arrow and and and flash and Supergirl
and legends of tomorrow see the black
lightning picture I did swing so they're
killing it in the movie world in the TV
world and you know look there are no
slouches in the movie world Batman V
Superman made eight hundred and fifty
million and squad you don't badly almost
eight hundred as well well not say it
wasn't bad but didn't do bad but Marvel
of course is Marvel Marvel Studios is
like read they're the Pixar of the 21st
century they can make no [ __ ] wrong
moves they are the edmonton oilers from
1984 to 88 of the 21st century follow
that analogy if you will there Miramax
circa 1989 to like right before they
picked up clerks every [ __ ] decision
they make is a [ __ ] smart one and
they're building this wild legacy now
and i'm so five and i got to tell you
this
it's a [ __ ] ton of boardroom see i don't
know how many seeds they got with the
brother and sister gone yeah but what
about Danny should we talk about like
profits and lost no dad no what about
Danny do you think it's in any should we
bring these drugs to the market for cost
or should we wrap it up for your making
money superheroes I like that scene it
was actually kind of good scene I mean
it's not that they're bad scenes it's
it's in LA los scene [ __ ] iron fist
he was iron law then okay so what we saw
this week ladies and gentlemen was a
phenomena that we've seen over and over
again in the age of the Marvel movie and
now they DC Warner Brothers and Marvel
Studios separately of course DC started
this week out with a [ __ ] bang
because on Saturday which is the
one-year anniversary of the release of
Batman V soup
the movie they dropped a trailer we like
days leading up to it little teaser
trailers and on Saturday that had
dropped the trailer for the Justice
League and the internet lit the [ __ ] up
and everybody was talking about Justice
League's number one trending topic all
over the world and [ __ ] people were just
like hey man this does look [ __ ] good
some serious haters were like you know
how [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm still holding out
and stuff but it was the topic of
discussion and everybody was like [ __ ]
and this movie is eight months away
until Tuesday then there is a great
chess game being played that we the
consumer are unaware of let's just
imagine Kevin Feige was just like oh did
DC have a good day let's drop the
spider-man trailer shall we check oh my
god check and [ __ ] mate and so you
got to talk about and be amazed by
Justice League for a minute and a half
before suddenly the amazing spider-man
trailer happened we're gonna talk about
both of those on separate shows but
that's not even the point of all this
that's just to say look at these big
maneuvers now this is all conspiracy
theory talk we know the big studios
would never sit there and be like pull
the trigger on that [ __ ] right now
they've gotta move things well in
advance like the Titanic we have to join
millions of dollars in swayed one
doesn't do those kind of decisions on a
whim sure feels like it though sure
[ __ ] feels like it something's on it
so amazing spider-man broke the [ __ ]
Internet it's one of the greatest
trailers ever produced man and boy oh
boy just looking into that trailer gives
you the same feeling at least I speak to
myself as a middle-aged 46 year old man
that I had when I was a child cracking
similar stories for the first time like
you know when I read born again I was
like 17
no 18 I read daredevil born again I'll
never get that same feeling back
although I could go to the page where
Matt is holding Karen I'll still roll a
[ __ ] tear cuz that's some beautiful
artwork but I think was David
Mazzucchelli wasn't it and and I'm just
the sentiment Matt's out of the wardrobe
he's just he's him and Karen betrayed
him man she sold out his identity to the
kingpin and kingpin has destroyed his
life and [ __ ] and he could he's within
his rights to be like [ __ ] Karen page
and then I'll ask Karen page is about to
be killed that billy club comes out no
I'm gonna do it so good you don't get
the ha [ __ ] it's amazing you don't get
that feeling like more than once you
open the book you're like holy [ __ ]
maybe they put in a trade paperback you
get that feeling second time but then
you go on in life and stuff and you're
like [ __ ] you chase that dragon for the
rest of your life and chances are you
will never feel that exact feeling you
felt looking at the book but with these
movies now second bite at the Apple
suddenly they're letting you feel the
way you felt when you cracked open those
books and you removed as a child you're
middle-aged man looking like less time
in front of them behind you and [ __ ] now
you're moved even more and even though
like you've watched your child be born
you watch that Spiderman trailer you're
like that's the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen in my life it's a marvel
only the [ __ ] weak man and you know
it was check and mate as Mark pointed
out except they unmated Warner Brothers
was like oh really then once again once
again in the great chess game that's
being played behind our backs man
between let's say the watcher and the
spectre ooh thank you good cause just
down off the tip of my tongue
oh the watcher was easy but I was like
whoo and DC I was like I'm give it to
the spectre just as if those two are
sitting there playing a game of chess
man with our hearts and emotions and and
our ups and downs as we root for you're
either a favorite DC or your favorite
Marvel DC dropped a [ __ ] megasonic
nuclear warhead teenage negasonic
nuclear war or middle-aged if you were
if I couldn't have dreamed of this but
why didn't we see this coming because it
was written in the stars you could have
seen this is a Shakespearean kids what
was about to happen you're about to find
out
Joss Whedon greater a Buffy the Vampire
Slayer and director of two not one but
two Avengers movies av Avengers movies
the the very heart soul and [ __ ] spine
of the Marvel Studios Universal a
bruiser of agents of shield one of the
architects of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like mr. Marvel movie side Jon
Favreau was the original mr. MA
without them you don't get a spot at
Ironman and Ironman is the is the
adamantium spine upon which the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is build man all
praise to Jon Favreau
but Whedon coming in [ __ ] that puts it
was the first time we saw a bunch of
superheroes together Avengers changes
the business everybody wants to Avengers
eyes their universe mark is working on
one of those shows
indeed and Joss Whedon leads directly to
the Russos like you don't you don't get
from that to that without just wait and
saying you know TV guys I'm not so bad
I'm a TV guy we can do this these guys
are super [ __ ] smart bring them in
help them give them a cab movie see what
happens so there's an architect you can
argue of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Joss Whedon and then after the age of
Ultron you know he was like I'm not
gonna do the next one you know broke me
yeah well at first it was like tired you
know the mother would - took a lot out
of me so I'm not gonna do him it was
curious who walks away from the trilogy
and stuff and then they replace them but
the Russo brothers and the Russo
brothers did civil war and we loved
Civil War so there seems to be a
continuity of service even though it
wasn't Joss Joss suddenly we were like
ah well we're still back in business
with our characters but that left a
major player off the board for quite
some time indeed strangely somebody with
experience in superhero cinematics and
I'm not gonna say someone with an ax to
grind but like mmm in somebody who once
upon a time dabbled in DC's waters where
there is a script that Joss Whedon was
paid to write wonder wonder woman years
ago yeah back in the early aughts so
prior to the marvel cinematic universe
indeed he was over there at Warner
Brothers and stuff and who better than
Joss Whedon to take that girl um you
know just imagine Buffy and I put a cowl
on her and stuff like that BAM lesbian
pyres more thugs but still and connected
to Batman which is something most of us
love in general but her own thing
standalone batgirls never had a
cinematic motion picture this is crazy
crazy but what's even crazier is a guy
who was an architect at marvel
literally crossed the [ __ ] Street man
this ain't like when you see an actor
who's been an oh they were in a Marvel
movie and a DC is Chris Evans crossing
screen no this ain't or even David small
chin who was wonderful abracadabra last
week in flash he was in The Dark Knight
and ant-man guy who walks between two
worlds and stuff like that actors you
can kind of get away with this rector's
not so much yes you know this would be
like Jon Favreau going and directing a
DC movie but this is even [ __ ] bigger
just like I like Jon memmer bro but he
there's two Avengers to Joss his name
there would be like George Lucas make it
a Star Trek movie this would be like
Stan Lee at the height of Marvel going
to DC and publishing a few books and I
don't mean like an amalgam stunt second
reference to amalgam this week more
references than the last ten years
because science happened for San
darkfall this is massive news and we're
gonna have to unpack this for further
analysis I turn to Mark Barnard give me
a single give him a single far further
makes me first me first there's anything
mark yes how does something like this
happen how did they let that cat get out
the bag and cross the street and and
join the other team you're talking about
a beleaguered
effort so far by DC a lot of people jump
it on their dick about it's too dark and
[ __ ] like that and they get the original
they signed to their [ __ ] bench mmm
the original like let's have adventures
and good times and laughs yes and and
everything is not muted colors primary
colors how does that how did they not
see that [ __ ] train come and give
Marcus it I think they didn't want to
see it coming
I think Marvel is totally happy with how
their things are moving I think that
they're in a world in which they haven't
again how to miss iron fist but first
but for DC's perspective like men I
think they are doing
they're building a bat verse they I
think they've forgiven the idea of we
are never seen a flash movie I honestly
believe we're never seen a flash movie
we are 100% never seen a cyborg movie
you know cyborg movie you put it on the
record
yeah but we will absolutely now see the
Nightwing movie yeah Batgirl movie a
solo Batman movie leading into a bat
family Trinity movie this should I even
my god we put that [ __ ] together like
Kevin Costner in JFK he's absolutely
[ __ ] right thank god this show is
called
[Laughter]
because they're not making a DC Universe
they're literally making a bat purse yes
I think they've realized that how we
wrest control from Zack Snyder is give
all of these other people things to do
and then build that other stream so
you've got Gotham girls where they conk
off
irons you've got the Nightwing movie
they announced now Joss Whedon's Batgirl
yep Matt Reeves is the Batman's is and
I'm sure there's something we're
forgetting yeah squad to which they will
eventually make which which may or may
not be directed by Mel Gibson did I read
that on their name yeah but that's yeah
neither here nor there no nobody knows
what's gonna happen but now you have
come on I'm gonna step over there that's
a whole discussion we do that but like
that's now for almost five movies
spooling up into Gotham Batman family
you're building a Gotham Universe
yeah like you know do we ever see the
the Green Lantern buddy cop movie maybe
probably not really I mean maybe they
make it who knows do you want it I don't
know if I want it I mean you want it I'm
the worst got ass cuz I want it all and
[ __ ] now and I would like it weekly like
you know I'm like a creature of the
internet where it's like that's amazing
show me something else yeah I feel like
it's you know we get Aquaman we get
Justice League we get Wonder Woman we
might get a Superman to maybe at some
point Man of Steel - probably not do you
think they're backing into a bat I think
they're back into that verse because the
bad verse will always make the money
they can try out different directors on
these bat movies and like maybe find a
dude who'll be an architect for that not
busy we know a guy
like a view goodbye tickets okay you're
not opening weekend though we don't
believe you come to me gaff to come
later on huh but yeah I feel like that
makes the most sense from both a studio
perspective from a money perspective
from a fan perspective you don't lose my
analysis you ain't getting anywhere else
on the interwebs kids [ __ ] mark
barnard not just a good [ __ ] writer
sharp sharp you see everything and now I
have no other outlet for this but this
no longer you can't [ __ ] write this
for the LA Times I would have been a
good [ __ ] piece to write I did phone
that one in like how Johnny Carson used
to phone in jokes I could do that just
call him up and be like hey I got a
piece for you um I would be for that I
think I like your theory and I think I'm
for that like why not just lead with
your greatest strength which is like all
Batman all the time and maybe they can't
just keep doing Batman but they're like
well you can do Batman without doing
Batman Suicide Squad show bad so let's
do this that girl and Batgirl whose time
came a long [ __ ] time ago in terms of
like why hasn't this happened prior yes
but thank the Lord it's happening in the
right hands it's like oh my god you were
ever gonna do Batgirl move and give it
to that guy that guy has proven that he
knows how to make a movie that makes
money at the box office
well that's always [ __ ] helpful and
he knows how to tell strong female lead
stories and he knows how to [ __ ] deal
in worlds that aren't normal worlds and
and action II and stuff were you a Buffy
guy I was a huge Buffy guy massive Buffy
guy yeah I was making [ __ ] so I wasn't
really a scene Buffy of course but like
I was not like not like I'm dedicated to
like the flash and Supergirl it is one
of the like texts of the sort of 20th
century in how you tell stories about
teenagers that don't feel diminutive
towards teenagers it's how you tell Jon
were stories in ways that respect the
genre and it's how you tell allegorical
stories in ways because Buffy is about
high school like it's about that every
episode was the what if that kid who you
never speak to happens to be a this what
if that that person who's got a problem
that problem is magic what if the first
boy you ever sleep with turns into a
dick just after you sleep with him like
but in this world that's a vampire right
you know it's it's let's find those
universal stories about
and give it a genre gloss that make it
somewhat different from every other show
on TV but universally applicable impact
is still absolutely felt and as much as
on those on the shows that I've worked
on for the CW they still speak in that
terminology they refer to the big bad
yeah you know he comes right from that
shooting season long arc of a big bad is
a is an absolute Buffy invention the
there's the there's the ongoing story of
your heroine but there is the
season-long story of your enemy and then
every season you can recycle them you
can bring them back if you want
like you know spike never really went
away but it was never the big bad for
the whole show but he's just always
alive they're always able to recycle and
reuse it was a very green show I feel
before Green was a big thing the service
and a [ __ ] Buffy addict yeah I've
spent some time in the buffy do you have
one of those angel puppets somewhere in
the house I'm not gonna say it might
incriminate me Joss Whedon's storyteller
episodic versus cinematic would you wish
you prefer I mean I feel like you get
more space in episodic you know like
it's it's a russian novel is making a TV
show yeah and you get a thousand pages
to write a thing and have it live and
breathe er make the characters vibrant
whereas on the screen you get 120 pages
to tell a story it could be an amazing
story it could be a wonderful story I'm
gonna tell amazing story but it's only
going to be that as opposed to we are
living with these characters for years
does this enhance or hurt the chances of
a Buffy reunion movie or something I
mean I at this point given that Sarah
Michelle Gellar is is not working and
David Boreanaz just came off of bones
like there's absolutely world where you
can make another one of those but this
is a girl jump in the way of it I mean I
don't think so
I mean a those folks aren't going
anywhere and the desire for more Buffy
is absolutely flying anniversary 20th
anniversary there's been a whole bunch
of [ __ ] around in like aw just been a
did a big reunion cover with that like
yeah like anything that use initials in
a foreign language stand for Buffy
magnet [ __ ]
they covered it when I was there yeah
and it was off the air I'm not saying
that I have we know why they [ __ ]
covered it while you were there cuz
you're like let's do another episode
it's like hey he's got a new show called
Firefly it's gonna be a huge hit it
wasn't over the [ __ ] out of it anyway
predictions with Mark no I I couldn't be
more excited for this and it sounds like
I read something today that it's the new
52 iteration of Barbara it makes the
most sense what does that just mean
she's not in a wheelchair it means she's
not in a wheelchair I mean she's younger
it means that it's the it's the ramping
up into into her world is Batgirl as
opposed to you know I'm a librarian this
is what I like about this mark regarding
tell me Kevin Smith Joss Whedon is
powerful storyteller powerful pop
cultural stories which means he has the
chance to write a Batgirl story which
more people will remember and identify
with Batgirl than the one Batgirl story
that's not a Batgirl story at all that
most people identify with Batgirl which
is killing Joe right like you know for a
lot of people back girls like most
famous exploit is getting shot by the
Joker Joss Whedon has a wonderful chance
here to rewrite that and I'm not saying
there's been plenty of comic books and
wonderful animated shows that have kind
of rewritten Barbara Gordon background
stuff but this is mainstream this is on
the on the canvass of the stars ladies
Jim this is the one that everybody sees
where your mom is like oh did you know
they're making Batgirl tiger so you know
he's got a chance here to kind of like
Matt not to I love Alan Moore and I love
The Killing Joke so it's not like erase
that mistake or whatever but that still
to this day most people I go back girl
she got shot but a joker like well or is
Yvonne Craig yeah those are the tax my
generation goes like you know who
Batgirl is to me sitting in front of
every episode of Batman praying to
Christ that a cartoon [ __ ] batcycle
would go pod cuz that meant there is
gonna be some background also featuring
Yvonne Craig his background yeah Joss
Whedon doing Batgirl that's the world we
live in man and in the ongoing war of
Marvel vs. DC DC has just taken a
massive fuckingly right the only way
this story or Marvel 1ups DC is if Chris
Nolan goes and makes a [ __ ] Marvel
right and also the other way that's
interesting is that now DC has made or
the barely says greenlit to female
starring movies Wonder Woman
Batgirl Marvel still just got the one
which they have Marvel Captain Marvel
which is 2019 like if you think that
makes I think Kevin Feige is a strong
player I don't think it makes him wrap
his schedule up at all he's like red no
Captain Marvel and when we do it it's
gonna be amazing
it'll be great I'm not worried we're
powerful everything we do is like
[ __ ] gold but it is one of those you
know like Scarlett Johansson's Ben Black
Widow for a while she could hold a movie
right Scarlett Johansson can open a
movie bar so Lucy kind of thing going on
here there's a she-hulk movie you might
wanna make how is the ghost in the
shield's post Oh open I think it's
tracking 430 million
why wouldn't they give her a black widow
mother makes no sense the moment I saw
Lucy open as big as ditto they're like
hey [ __ ] you're on yeah you're on a
Black Widow solo movie script don't make
it but they are they've got a you know
they're like the Cylons they've got a
plan I'm not talking deviate from it and
with good reason it's worked so far too
hard when I was like we're smarting from
losing Josh you're still [ __ ] saying
iron fist
put iron fist in this mark barnard there
it is folks [ __ ] huge geek news and
we had to share it with you and stuff
fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm
mark barnard come back next episode same
fat time same fat channel SModcast calm
for youtube.com slash Kevin Smith oh man
trailer next what snake
[Music]
you
[Music]